foreign
decade ago
I met someone who had experienced a few
episodes of schizophrenia
they had felt that their sense of self
of what it feels like to be them
changing somewhat
the boundaries of their body began to
feel a bit nebulous
even their psychological self
a bit porous at times
they were experiencing what could be
called an altered sense of self
over the years I met many such Brave and
insightful people who shared what it's
like to live with their altered selves
and by altered I mean different not
deficient
while acknowledging that coping with
altered cells
can be a struggle at times
So speaking with them and with
theologians philosophers
neuroscientists I came to understand
that this self that each one of us takes
oneself to be
is not as real as it seems
the self is a slippery subject
we all intuitively know what it means
it's there when we wake up it disappears
when we fall asleep
it reappears in our dreams
it's what makes us who we are
it seems solid unchanging permanent
and yet we can examine aspects of the
self that seem real to us
and ask just how real are they
take for instance the question who am I
the most likely answer you'll get or
give to such a question
will be in the form of a story
we tell others and indeed ourselves
stories about Who We Are
we take our stories to be sacrosanct we
are our stories
but a condition that most of us sadly
will be familiar with Alzheimer's
disease
tells us something quite different
Alzheimer's Begins by affecting
short-term memory
think about what that does to someone's
story
in order for our stories to form to grow
something that just happens to us has to
First enter short-term memory
and then get incorporated into what's
called long-term episodic memory it has
to become an episode in our narrative
but what if the experience doesn't even
enter short-term memory
that's exactly what Alzheimer's does in
the beginning Alzheimer's impairs the
formation of short-term memory it
impairs the growth of the narrative it's
as if our stories begin stalling upon
the onset of the disease
eventually Alzheimer's eats away at
older long-term memories so if you were
to meet someone with mid-stage
Alzheimer's
they will likely be able to tell you
stories about who they are
but if you know the real stories
you'll be able to tell that they
sometimes scramble up their narrative
that they sometimes mix up the sequence
of episodes from their lives it's as if
they are recalling their own stories in
ways that are not quite accurate
it's important at this stage to realize
that there is still a person
experiencing that scrambled narrative
sadly Alzheimer's goes on to destroy
one's narrative and so much more
and towards the end it's unclear whether
there is still someone experiencing
something
because a person cannot communicate
verbally anymore
and yet
Alzheimer's tells us that these stories
that we take ourselves to be
what philosophers call The Narrative
self
these are spun by the brain and body
they are constructions sometimes the
constructions are disrupted even
destroyed
and while that is horrific for the
person experiencing it and for their
caregivers
it is nonetheless a window onto the
constructed nature of our narrative self
and when the construction goes wrong we
perceive our own stories in ways that
are not quite real
from The Narrative self let's talk about
our body
let's take a very basic aspect of our
bodily self this feeling we all have
that we are owners of our body and body
parts that our bodies and body parts
belong to us
it seems such a strange thing to think
that it could even be otherwise
if I were to ask you does your hand
belong to you
you're going to say of course it does
what a foolish question
but not everyone would agree
early on in my research
a neuropsychologist alerted me to a
condition called xenomilia or foreign
limb syndrome
you may have heard of something called
Phantom limb syndrome
in which people
who have had an amputation feel the
presence of that limb sometimes
xenomilia is somewhat of an opposite
condition
where people feel like some part of
their body usually the extremities of
their hands or legs don't belong to them
so this neuropsychologist talked of
phantom limb syndrome as animation
without incarnation
so the limb is gone it's not incarnate
anymore but it's animated in your mind
and he talked of xenomilia as
Incarnation without animation
so the limb is present healthy even
incarnate and yet in your own mind it
feels like it doesn't belong to you
so in xenomilia the brain and bodily
processes that give rise to our sense of
ownership of our body parts
they're misfiring so to speak
and the consequences can be serious
people with xenomilia will sometimes
take Extreme Measures to get rid of to
amputate their foreign seeming body
parts
from the perspective of the self though
xenomilia is telling us something very
profound it's telling us that something
as basic as the sense of ownership of
our own body parts is a construction
and sometimes the construction goes
wrong and we perceive our own bodies in
ways that are not quite real
let's take another aspect of our bodily
self
it's called the sense of agency
so when I do something like pick up a
cup
I have this implicit feeling that I am
the agent of that action that I have
willed that action into existence that
feeling is the sense of agency
but someone with schizophrenia may not
have that feeling always someone with
schizophrenia might do something and not
feel like they are the agent of that
action
so schizophrenia tells us that it is
possible to be someone who does
something but doesn't have an
accompanying sense of agency
so just like the narrative self and the
sense of ownership of body parts the
sense of agency is also a construction
and it too can fail
so you can see where this is going
let me take one more example to drive
home this point let's talk of what it
feels to be a body Here and Now
not the feeling of being a story but the
feeling of being a body in the present
moment
psychologists estimate that about five
percent of the general population will
at some point in their lives have an out
of Body Experience
let's assume all of us right now are
having an in-body experience
but what that means is having this
feeling of being in a body
being anchored to a body occupying a
certain volume of space
and looking at the world from behind our
eyes
but if you are having an outer body
experience you could possibly be feeling
that you're up near the ceiling looking
down at your own body sitting in the
chair below
people do report such experiences and
Mild versions of this have been
replicated in labs
but if you think like I do that out of
body experiences are the outcome of
brain processes that are misfiring then
it stands to reason that the experience
of being in body of being embodied is
itself for construction and that too can
come apart
so what are these experiences of altered
selves telling us
they are telling us that just about
everything we take to be real about
ourselves
real in the sense that we think we are
always experiencing undeniable truths
about our bodies our stories well that's
just not the case
so when theologians and philosophers
tell us that the self is an illusion
this is partly what they mean
you may have realized by now that there
Still Remains the question
of who or what is doing the experiencing
even in the case of altered selves
this experiencing I in the question who
am I is at the heart of the debate about
the self
this experiencing I doesn't go away if
one or a few aspects of the self are
disrupted
but what if all of the aspects of the
self that comprise us were to be
disrupted would the experiencing eye
disappear
we don't have a satisfactory answer to
that question
yet
it's possible that the experiencing eye
is also an illusion in the sense of
being a construction a construction
without a Constructor
that debate however is somewhat
unresolved
despite such doubts I personally
whatever I am
think that the self has no reality
outside of the brain and body
I think that the experiencing eye will
not persist after the body is gone
so what does one make of such knowledge
well firstly
these ideas will feel liberating to some
and might sit heavily upon others
regardless I think we can all attend to
the stories that we think we are
our feelings and emotions are modulated
by our stories and in turn our feelings
and emotions become part of our stories
and our stories our narratives are not
just cognitive they live in our bodies
and our bodies structure and shape our
stories
so knowing all this recognizing the
constructed nature of it all maybe we
can hold on less tightly to our stories
maybe we can learn to let go
but that's easier said than done because
the thing that is doing the letting go
is also the thing that has to be let go
of
maybe we can just marvel at the efforts
of people over millennia from the Buddha
sitting under the Bodhi Tree to the
modern philosopher and neuroscientists
who have asked themselves the question
who am I
but most of all
I think we over debt to those amongst us
who bravely bear witness to our altered
selves whether we do so voluntarily like
monks and nuns do when they meditate
or whether it's brought Upon Us by
biology and Circumstance
there is something remarkably robust
about the processes that give rise to
the totality of our sense of self
but there's something frighteningly
fragile about them too they can crack
and any one of us at any time in our
lives may have to confront such cracks
and that knowledge I believe should make
us empathetic towards those of us
dealing with altered selves
but
I also believe that altered self should
not be seen as the outcome of deficits
or as the outcome of a lack of
attributes considered normal
there are different ways of being
and it's the willingness of some of us
to confront the self-constructed nature
that is helping make sense of the self
for all of us
thank you
[Applause]